Other than that, I wonder if everyone has already confirmed the team
[Music]
This season it's
you, and
then ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah I
'm in trouble with my plain children I'll bury it for 10 years
my poison is a web of dirt nuts  Line up,
fill everyone in,
who is Dara? Really Burger
[music]
Always with the bus This icy sound is a
little cute together
But it's mine, so don't mess around  I
'm on the same team as this cool
guy who's called my childhood friend.  We
're on the same team Nice to meet you I think we'll be strong teammates together Kanei
[music]
ah ah ah ah
I'm anxiously laughing -
both of us are laughing
My sister won't come to the world in terms of ability
.